comment il va comme on les aime
mission impossible un fallout
votre mission si toutefois vous
l'acceptez je me tais rage on avez vous
déjà reçu celle la fin que vous
redoutiez est proche
et c'est vous qui aurez ces morts sur la
conscience les conséquences de vos
bonnes intentions
[Musique]
vous avez pris une décision difficile à
berlin une vie perdue pour en sauver des
millions cette fois c'est le monde
entier qui est en danger c'est la
mission de la cia
s'il avait gardé le plutonium nous
n'aurions pas cette conversation toute
son équipe seraient mortes
oui probablement ce sont les risques du
métier
[Musique]
tu ne sais pas de quoi tu t'es engagé tu
ferais mieux de temps là les s'il te
plaît ne me dit pas contre toi combien
de fois hunt at il été trahi par son
gouvernement désavoué mis sur la touche
combien de temps un homme comme lui
peut-il supporter ça avant de décider
que ça suffit
ça ne ressemble pas à l'état
peut-être qu'il est temps que ça change
et
[Musique]
alors comment il va tu sais comme on les
aime
qu'est ce qu'il fait je crois qu'il vaut
mieux pas regardé